Ukraine's President Vladimir solenski
says it's vital to keep pushing Russia
to participate in what he calls genuine
peace talks earlier an advisor to
solenski said Ukraine was ready for
talks with a Russian leader but not
Vladimir Putin U.S media have also
reported that the Biden Administration
has been encouraging Ukraine to Signal
openness to talks the Kremlin has said
it's open to negotiations this comes as
Ukraine welcomes the arrival of new air
defense systems supplied by Norway Spain
and the US
DW correspondent Nick Connelly is in
Kiev he told us how important these
Western defense systems will be
well they're certainly very welcome
they've been promised for long time and
now they're finally here although we're
not being told quite how many have
reached uh Kiev so far of the total
number promised and even the total of
some promised is only a fraction of
what's needed to protect this country or
this is after all a war that's being
fought on a scale bigger than anything
that any Western country has fought in
decades front lines of over a thousand
kilometers and cities hundreds of
kilometers away from those front lines
routinely being hit so those nasam's
rockets that are coming from the US
they're used to protect the White House
they're pretty modern they would develop
nearly 2000s they're kind of close to
medium range and then the Rockets coming
from Spain they're a bit older kind of
more 70s 80s and they are short range
but this is all very welcome there is
obviously a worry that this is too much
too different kit there's you know kit
that's come from Germany and other kit
coming from France a couple of weeks so
the Ukrainian Army release Huntington
basically make do with all the kind of
leftovers that Western militaries have
and are willing to part with but it's
definitely psychologically very
important to think that there's
something to deal with these attacks
they've left people feeling so
vulnerable
that was DW correspondent Nick Connelly
reporting from the Ukrainian Capital as
the war in Ukraine continues many people
are looking for missing loved ones many
are feared dead but in some cases no
bodies have been found leading relatives
to hope they may have survived often the
only way of finding out the painful
truth is a DNA test DW's Matthias
Bollinger spoke to people in izium a
town recently retaken from Russian
forces
they wait to see the investigators
bringing DNA and testimony Ludmila
Roshana and her relative just have
questions about herself he was serving
in the Ukraine territorial Defense Force
when the Russians came to Izu she lost
contact but didn't dare to ask too much
everyone knew the Russians were looking
for families of Ukrainian soldiers
I hid
I was afraid that someone might tip them
off we had a lot of my son's military
stuff at home I was very scared
now the Russians are gone the world can
see what the fighting did to his Zoom at
the beginning of the war
and details are emerging from the sixth
month of occupation these include a mass
grave on the outskirts of town
their investigators found the bodies of
civilians as well as Ukrainian soldiers
some with their hands tied behind their
backs
more than 400 bodies were found here
it's the biggest Mass grave detected
a mobile DNA sampling unit
for many a cheek swap offers the only
hope for clarity many of the bodies in
the mass Graves were in such bad
condition that immediate identification
wasn't possible
today Nadia Ivanova will give a sample
she fled with her child just before the
Russians arrived leaving her father in
hospital later she heard the hospital
was shelled
I found a doctor from izum who had fled
the town
he told me that my father died in the
attack and it had not been possible to
save him
he died there and was left behind
now she's looking for his body
nude if he is she's doing the same her
son is said to have died in an air raid
soldiers from his unit can offer her
little hope
unfortunately if you consider where he
was when the bomb hit
there's no chance he could have survived
but they never found his body and so
don't know for certain what happened the
soldiers are here to testify
udmila has already given investigators a
DNA sample but hasn't heard anything
her relative tries to find out more but
there's no news today
as long as there's no body I still have
hope
although not much
thank you
[Music]
the soldiers promised the women that
they'd stay in touch
that's all anyone can do